did i hear on the news you got a new
superman tattoo
maybe
is that true or was the news wrong
that's right
what the [ __ ] are you doing with the
superman tattoo you don't even like
superman i love superman you know
anything no it's not i'm not an expert
on superman and superman's name but i
used to i used to watch with george
reeves with superman i used to watch
when i was a kid
i loved the show he's got it but this
thing you've got to be the oldest guy
who ever got a superman it's not the
suit it's the new one it's not the old
one it's from the new movie one what
planet is superman from krypton okay
what was superman's father's name i
don't remember what's superman's name on
on on on krypton
how do you [ __ ] know what does that
have to do with that if you put it
because i like somebody
because i like something that's bad holy
mackerel oh come on man first of all his
name is kyle
okay whoopee and jorel is his father
thrilled
i'm thrilled to no end what's the
phantom zone that you should know from
the movie
zone you know what the fandom's on this
no
oh my god i always liked the logo but i
would never put the old superman on
because everybody let me see your
superman logo why do you have to make it
oh you got my clothes
where'd you go to get it it's on my
shoulder all right let me let me see it
sleep wild child
what has that got to do with stephanie
the superman this is the in lieu of an
engagement
what oh that's in lieu of an engagement
yeah you know now he's gonna start two
ways that's been in a 10-carat
engagement ring to her
it is
all right
i tattooed my body but it's the superman
logo has nothing to do with stephanie
no offense yeah nobody's going to sit
there and look at that and go wow
this is for superman not for stephanie
but there's both the initials look at
his arms look at this
nuts oh my god oh my gosh oh what's
wrong
hey superman
i'm superman
let me see wait wait let me turn it
toward me turn me turn the superman logo
toward me
wow looks like a badge
how is that for stephanie
s is for superman not stephanie
well in your mind
he knows nothing about superman what
does that have to do i don't care
because it means you're a fan of
superman i am a fan assuming doesn't
mean i have to know his history and
everything about it i used to watch the
tv show i liked the tv show all right on
the tv show who were the guys who came
up from middle earth to attack superman
i remember that but you don't know
anything i'll okay uh
uh why do i have to know anything
what is up with that they're called the
mole men by the way you know his
girlfriend's name right lois lane okay
okay all right there you go and perry
white and all those people
and all three people what newspaper do
they work for the daily planet all right
okay okay well you better learn some
city
[Music]
which city the city
i don't know the hell city was looked
like l.a to me
l.a
the daily planet building looked like
l.a
could you recite the opening to superman
what do you mean recycle than a speeding
bullet yeah more powerful than a
locomotive right able to leap tall
buildings at a single bound look up in
the sky it's a bird it's a plane
it's superman okay you happy now
the hell's wrong with you